[Applaudissements]
l'arête des pnj oui vous allez descendre
joue plus peut-être soignerait n'oublie
le chauffeur viendra les chercher en fin
de journée
bonjour à l'autorité la route était
tranquille la route ville et la ceinture
noire
690 gay têtu présentait au kenya
castellet bonjour
monsieur payet vous savez un buggy cette
journée c'est tout le monde ya tout à
faire on va pouvoir y allant du mois
bonjour je suis sûr de vous accueillir
et à la vie dans le quartier mais pour
qui a beaucoup d'histoire car vos en
tête ont parcouru de sentiers je vous
distribuer des cartes
pour ne pas vous perdre en chemin
bon allez y vit on a beaucoup de chemin
à faire
deux étapes sous le bras on garde la
cadence en 2h06
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces trésors cachés nous permettront
d'avoir une nouvelle vie
ailleurs monbana ça c'est le grand soin
ne s'arr nous les bété
et varennes sp pas de notre chemin
à la note 4 août chemin
le chemin de la rivière ou pas et finit
par
nous remontent la montagne
le paradou la liberté danny
[Musique]
way
[Applaudissements]
maintenant je fais pas les perdre on est
là il va pas être loin au delà de la
cote
non non non je comprends pas là on a
fait ce parcours
non
[Applaudissements]
là c'est pas possible
[Rires]
nous un truc bizarre
narré dans le passé de thé marron et ne
touchant la liberté samedi trop bizarre
à rester si n'importe quoi non retard
entre dans le but
voilà montrent la hôpitaux fouchères
voilà trouvera des manies avec son
langage des six mois l'apa son langage à
terme à la maladie baugé bâtiment a
commenté la fougue et à mahfad moutet
l'essence dans la casse asma grosbois
salle est long à la tipa tipa l'arrivée